new tonight the Las Vegas Review Journal
is seeking action against Metro Police
they argue the police department
illegally searched devices belonging to
reporter Jeff Garman shortly after his
death violating Nevada's Shield law
court documents indicate Metro
identified Rob tell us as a person of
interest in gearman's Murder based on
information found while searching a
phone the RJ claims that search happened
before legal efforts could be made to
prevent it Metro Police have not said if
any phone search took place now
regarding the motion filed in court
executive editor for the review journal
says it would be a travesty of Jeff
gearman's murder resulted in authorities
learning the identities of his sources
adding that quote a reporter's murder
shouldn't end the reporter's Shield law
and First Amendment protections now so
far Metro has not commented publicly on
this matter